You can change the world
to meet your values when
you are in government.
You can't when you
are in opposition.
Getting into government has to
be the first and sole purpose
of any political party.
I was there in the 1980s when
the hard left held a dominant
position in the Labour party.
When Labour had 18, 19 years
of continuous opposition.
And I learned the
hard way really,
that extreme left politics just
didn't connect to the voters.
But I was also there in
1997 and through the years
of the Blair-Brown governments.
When I saw what impact
one could have when we
controlled the levers of power.
I am virtually the last Jewish
woman Labour MPs left standing.
If we don't learn the
lessons of why we have
lost the 2019 election.
If we allow the heir to Corbyn
to be Rebecca Long-Bailey...
Did you stand up at any
point, and call it out?
I did, but was that enough?
No.
It wasn't.
The idea that we will ever
get a Labour government,
certainly in my
lifetime, will disappear.
I mean, if I had a majority
of 80 Margaret, just think...
...even just one thing,
you'd be like giddy.
Like a child in a sweet shop.
The last four years, we have
to be honest with people,
it's been a fucking disaster
for the Labour party.
The last thing I want
is more, more Corbyn.
You said last time you
wanted to win, didn't you?
I've known Corbyn since '82.
If there's one thing
he really believes in,
it's all that massive
world view, which
is hostile to Nato,
hostile to the States,
leads to the anti-Semitism.
Rebecca.
We're going to take ....
once Adrian's finished.
I didn't break rank
and tell people
what's going on in
the shadow cabinet,
on this or anything
else, because I
don't think you should.
I consider my position
in the Labour party,
over the last few
years, to be honest...
I put myself
forward, for frankly,
the worst job in the world,
which is being leader
of the Labour party when
we're in opposition.
For me, I'm going
for Jess Phillips.
When I've seen the
others against her,
a lot of sort of
traditional politicians.
We need someone who can
stand opposite Boris Johnson,
and wear his
government in his face.
The Labour leadership race
is narrowing from 5 to 4.
This time, that person isn't me.
Oh.
So, Jess was due to come
and speak at the event.
Yeah.
But she's gone back to
Birmingham, so she can't.
Yeah.
We've sent her some flowers.
What could have been?
Oh goodness, that
is really hard.
I mean, I watched Jess's
video, and it's really moving,
and I wanted to cry when I
watched that for I think,
what the Labour party's lost.
But I'm a sort of, you know,
I'm an old, old fighter,
that's the real truth.
So I'm going to
carry on fighting.
And I just want to see
what the other candidates,
there's three of them
really, that I'm looking at.
Who can fill the void that
Jess's departure has created.
When I've seen the others
against a lot of the most
sort of traditional politicians,
men in suits quite often.
He's triangulating like mad.
Somebody said to
me, I don't mind
what he does as long as he
wins, beats Rebecca Long-Bailey.
And I thought you know,
Tony never did that.
Tony was completely
straight, completely honest.
It's a different way
of doing your politics.
So is Keir lying to get the job?
And will he then change?
That's what this
person was saying to me
as a way of promoting Keir.
I mean that's...
so I know.
So it's sort of, in a
way, you then think, um.
Right.
Who's not got
their seat belt on?
Those people who chose
to join Momentum,
I think probably a
lot have left now,
are young idealists
for whom at the time
Corbyn was a message of hope.
They are the ones who
don't like the politics,
don't like the
anti-Semitism, and don't
like the anti-Europeanism.
You'll start to see this in
who's nominating Keir Starmer.
You know, Momentum is cracking
up, it's sort of you know,
the old Trots will
all go for Rebecca.
As will the out-of-date,
fat bellied, beer bellied,
trade union barons.
I don't know where's Owen.
Is Owen pro-European?
Probably he is, actually.
I am cross because he
is 40 minutes late.
You know, everybody's
busy, and you just -
if you busy people
make me busy people,
don't piss him off
for being late.
Anyway, we are where we are.
Why do I talk to him?
Because Owen is a
Corbyn supporter,
and also he's been a
pretty consistent critic
of the Blair-Brown years,
actually of Labour in power
and in government, and I want
to challenge him a little bit
on that too.
You are very late.
I've been in the Labour
party for a very long time.
Longer than I've been alive.
Indeed.
So I remember the 80s, which you
know were very uncomfortable.
Where you used to go along
to Labour party meetings
and if you dare to put up your
hand on something you believed
in - all you were doing
was following your values,
which may be different,
there was intolerance of it.
People would shout abuse at you.
I had bricks thrown at
me during discussions
on cuts in local government.
I did.
I've had death threats.
I've had it all my life, and
I got it from the left then.
The Labour party
then went through,
under the Blair-Brown years,
which you like to dismiss.
I don't dismiss.
That's not true.
OK.
The Labour party went...
I was a Labour member
under Blair and Brown.
Brilliant.
Well, I'm really pleased.
So it went through a
really tolerant period,
when you could get up and you
could dissent within the party.
That wasn't my experience
at the time, by the way.
It was the experience for
the victors, but - no,
anyone to the left...
You wouldn't have
been shouted at.
Trots.
All the time.
Used a catch-all term for
anyone vaguely on the left.
All the time.
OK, that was not my experience.
There was a much
more open discourse.
But it's not...
because you were on
the winning side.
No.
Of course you didn't get...
No, I just...
You'd won.
Your side won and the left
fell ostracised and besieged.
Well, can I just say, this
left-right really irritates me.
Really irritateS,
it does irritate me.
Because you know,
here you are...
There's a left and right
flank of the Labour party.
That's just...
I mean, people on the...
Yeah, but I do not
understand what it means.
Because I think your
definition of left,
which is around big
state, nationalisation...
Democratic.
Democratic ...
No, it was...
you're joking.
No, I'm not joking.
I've just been through
reselection, Owen, OK?
Right.
In my party.
The whole triggering of
that process was by the few,
to defeat the will of the many.
So all this stuff about
we're fantastic, democratic.
The Labour party
now is the most...
You won the selection.
...intolerant,
centralised, bullying.
It's a terrible,
terrible institution.
OK.
I obviously strongly
disagree with that.
And I don't think
democracy is bullying.
You won your selection.
It isn't democracy.
You won your selection
fair and square
because the many voted for you.
But the fact I went
into it in the run-up,
is completely crazy.
It distracted me
from what I should
have been doing, because it
was obvious we were going
to get a general
election, and I should
have been out there
in the community
reconnecting with my voters.
Can I ask you?
This, I think,
because here we are.
We are from different
wings of the Labour family,
let's just put it that way.
But it's interesting
we're having
this argument, or
discussion, or whatever
you want to call
it, when actually,
if we're honest
and humble, neither
of our brands of politics have
any easy answers at the moment.
And the reason I say that is,
you talk about the 90s, Blair
and Brown and so on.
A period before the
financial crash.
A period of rising
living standards.
There was a financial
bubble at the time,
which seemed to be generating
ever rising living standards.
The problem is at the moment,
there is a general crisis...
Yeah.
...of social democracy, and
there is nowhere either of us
can point to on a
map and say, aha,
here's where my brand
of politics has truly,
truly flourishing.
Because Clinton was
defeated by Trump.
We're agreeing on this.
But that's why I look
at this mess now.
I mean, what's the
answer to that?
I don't have one.
I don't have on either.
I mean that - I agree with
you about the challenge.
I think it's really tough.
I think it's really,
really tough how you build
on the eternal values, which I
hope you and I do agree about,
and challenges, which I think
lead to massive insecurity,
so the changing world of
work and artificial...
Climate crisis.
All those are really tough
challenges for the left.
But that's...
And that, I would
love to talk about.
That in fact, on that, that's
what I'd be fascinated to hear.
Because I think even some
more perceptive thinkers
on your flank of
the Labour party.
Don't call me a flank.
I get...
Well I can't call
you from the right,
because you get even
angrier about that.
Is that wing, was politically
and intellectually
exhausted in 2015.
It was.
What I would say is the
challenge facing anyone
who does become leader is huge.
With a culture war which has
opened up in British society,
which Brexit both kind of
encouraged, but also reflected,
and has wreaked havoc in
Labour's electoral coalition.
And I don't think anyone, from
whatever wing of the Labour
party, has an easy answer, to
how they bring younger people
from - who are
economically insecure -
and have very strong
progressive values,
which they think
are under attack,
with older people who rightly
have their triple-lock pensions
protected, home
ownership's gone up,
and they feel quite
socially conservative.
And how Labour wins
some of those over,
and keeps their younger
voters, is a real challenge.
And I think all of us be
humble about discussing how
difficult...
You know, I totally
agree with that analysis,
and I just hope
that there can be
a civilised, non-blaming debate
about what are really, really
tough issues.
These are probably the
toughest philosophical,
political issues,
that I have confronted
in my very long political life.
Hi, It's Margaret Hodge.
Listen, I'm ringing
you about next Thursday
when we've got the meeting to
do the nomination for leader.
I mean, this is
really important,
getting the right leader.
You know, if we want to bring
the party back to sensible
Labour politics, you know.
OK, thanks so, so much,
and see you on Thursday.
Bye.
Well, I don't know
where Sienna is, but...
I'm going to go and
try and find her.
Are you?
Good, because otherwise
it can be chaos.
We're going to be here
forever otherwise, Cameron.
I really believe that
the Corbyn project,
the socialist manifesto, the
return to true Labour values,
has actually been a
really good success.
Would you like some...
No, thank you very much, indeed.
The last thing I want
is more, more Corbyn.
You should be
thinking about it too.
You think...
Well, you said the last time
you wanted to win, didn't you?
Are you a member of
the Labour party?
Are you?
Should we just count
them up now and close it?
Um.
Fingers crossed.
15, 16, 27, 28.
Two short of the required
number to get 50 per cent.
So did Emily...
...candidate, and
we go on eliminated.
The result is - Keir Starmer
is number one, so he won.
So...
The continuity candidate
didn't get anywhere tonight.
And I've always
said well, you know,
there are arguments
for Lisa and for Keir.
I would have marginally
gone for Lisa,
but I'm absolutely
delighted that we've
got a sensible candidate.
A sensible candidate
from this constituency.
I don't think you can
just sort of say, oh well,
let's assume Corbyn isn't gone.
Because the party is...
I think the party has
changed fundamentally.
You can see this in the
leadership election going on
now.
None of them can quite
bring themselves to say
that Corbynism was a disaster.
Jeremy is this sort
of sainted figure.
I mean, I agree
with you about that.
I so agree with you, because
there's a central dishonesty
in the non-Corbyn candidates.
Yeah.
You know.
And if you compare
that to Kinnock,
Kinnock when he fought for the
leadership of the Labour party
in the 80s, came from the left
but he was completely honest
about the sort of reform
that had to be undertaken.
I mean, Neil was very good a
kind of, political management.
But I had a very
interesting exchange
with Keir when he launched
his leadership video.
And it was you know,
miners' strike and poll tax.
And I sent him a message saying,
I'm really pleased that I gave
most of my adult life to
trying to help the Labour party
into power.
Three terms in office, so that
a future leader could launch his
campaign, where the only
mentions of that period
of Labour in office were the
Iraq war and cutting asylum
seekers' benefits.
And it's just playing into
that Corbynist agenda.
So he then sent me a message
back and said, yeah well,
I'm doing this new thing
now where I'm saying,
we shouldn't trash
the last four years,
and we shouldn't trash the
last Labour government.
Like they recall.
The last four years, I
get why he can't say it,
but we have to be
honest with people,
it's been a fucking disaster
for the Labour party.
The elections alone
were a disaster.
I think too much of our
politics is about saying, oh,
this is what people want to
hear, let's say that to them
and play it back to them.
So when...
You did a bit of
that in the 80s.
I did a bit of it.
You did a bit.
The message can be
simple, but it's
got to be underpinned by
something that is real.
Real policy, real stuff,
real choice, real decision.
If you look at our last
election, Corbyn or Johnson.
The country was
repelled by the choice,
but in the end realised well,
we have to make a... we have
to choose one of them.
One of them is going
to be prime minister.
Who's it going to be?
But go beyond that.
So we got a charismatic leader.
I feel more confident than
you do that we're going to get
a change of leader and that
will try and put us back...
Oh, we are.
There's definitely going
to be a change of leader.
Well, it's not going to
be Rebecca Long-Bailey.
Right.
OK.
It's my view.
Well, if it is
Rebecca Long-Bailey,
I think that's the end.
I agree.
I think we might
as well go home.
Some of the values that
now inform people's voting
decisions are really
hard for us to tackle.
So let's assume we've got
a charismatic leader who
can connect to people.
How are they going to tackle
the issues of immigration?
Which is really tough.
Which we have to think
about, we didn't do.
We didn't really get
to the bottom of.
And how are they going to tackle
tax and spend in an environment
where people don't want that?
How can I create a more equal
society, out of this brief
that I've now been given.
This is why I think
it goes beyond what...
Corbynism goes beyond who
actually becomes the leader.
You know, look, I can't stand
Johnson on many, many levels,
but one of the reasons he won is
that, he gave a kind of, albeit
riddled with lies and all
that, he gave a sense of kind
of, optimism to people.
Yeah, and hope.
So I would say, take
all of those issues
you mentioned, climate
change being the biggest.
I think a leader who came
out now and was truthful
about the consequences
of climate change,
and really led on them,
and really fought on them,
gives themselves
a fighting chance.
The other thing that's
changed I think -
the left-right arguments are
less straightforward than they
were.
But I hate this term left-right.
I mean...
But we're trapped in it.
Don't underestimate
the impact of Trump
in framing the debate
right around the world.
The whole kind of nationalist,
populist language,
Yeah.
That is easy to
articulate, it's easier
to get people to resonate with.
So but the way you
frame the debate
is to decide that is the
debate I'm going to frame.
Now, at the moment, I feel
that it's being framed within
this...
Historical analysis
of the Labour party.
Pretty much, yeah.
Terrible.
Yeah.
The other thing that
fills me with hope
is the leader we
elect now is unlikely
ever to become prime minister,
given the mountain we
have to climb back.
I don't think you
should say that.
You don't think we
should say that?
You think it's so volatile
that we can't bring it back...
Yeah.
I think things are so volatile,
things move so quickly.
I think some of the most...
That is... that will definitely
be the case if the leader that
the Labour party
elects plays safe.
So if I were leader
tomorrow, what
would I do to create
something true to my lasting
values, relevant to today,
that gets me a majority?
OK.
Well neither you and
I would be elected,
because I think we
would both start
from a position
of saying, we have
to be absolutely honest about
how we've got to this position.
And we have to be absolutely
honest about the challenges we
face to get back.
So I would build it on
understanding and accepting
that the right, the
nationalist, populist right,
is going to be very
difficult to beat.
And then saying they will
not be beaten by aping them.
They won't be beaten by
beating them halfway.
They have to be beaten by
a bigger better, bolder,
more optimistic vision
about what Britain can be.
This idea that, you
know, that it's all
got to be about getting
the right northerner,
as a response to the
north just putting
a bloody old Etonian in power.
They won the referendum.
They won the election.
They have a lot more
power than they did.
Now, the difference, I think,
between when I was with Tony,
and Cummings now
with Johnson, I never
really had an agenda of my own.
I had things I agreed with, and
things that I disagree with,
but I kind of, I didn't see
my position as been there
for my agenda.
Go on.
You're back in the Labour party.
You've got to vote Alastair.
How would you use it
for the leadership?
Well, I'm not back
in the Labour party.
Yeah, but assume.
Eh.
I think probably Keir.
Probably Keir.
And do you think he
can turn it around?
I really don't know,
because I think it's...
I think a lot of these
top jobs in politics,
I don't think you really
know until they get to them.
My fear is that the only
way he can turn it around
is by doing something different
from what he's telling us
he's going to do now.
I think the short answer
is, I don't think any of us
know yet, whether
they've got it in them.
I've taken over the chair of
the, the parliamentary chair
of the Jewish Labour movement.
Really, because everybody
else who's done has gone.
Scary, but it's true.
And there are very,
very few Jews now,
on the Labour side
in parliament.
And probably I'm
the only one who
is willing to put my
head above the parapet,
around my Jewish identity.
And also it's symbolic of what
the Labour party ought to be
all about.
How we're going to build
that confidence quickly?
It was really uncomfortable
for me during the election,
going out and trying to persuade
Jewish people to vote Labour.
Oh my God, there's going to
be absolutely loads of people,
aren't there?
700 people.
Jews come in all different
shapes and sizes.
... but I'm the only
one whose fucking left.
Are they not going to come in?
No.
They're just going to ...
I was going to ask
some questions.
That - we're going to bring
them on a - we're going
to bring them all on together.
It's fine, but we
need to begin now.
Otherwise, we're going to...
OK.
Thanks Mike, and thanks for
giving me the opportunity
to say a few words, because I am
virtually the last Jewish woman
Labour MP left standing.
Rebecca, we are going to take
them in once Adrian's finished.
If you look at after
the war and before,
to the mid '70s, most Jewish MPs
were Labour MPs because being
in the Labour party was
the natural home for Jews.
Sadly, we're not in
that position today.
I hope the candidates...
I was hoping they'd be in when I
said all this, but they're not.
So maybe some of you can ask
them the questions afterwards.
I think for all of us, I felt
at the last four years, for me,
have been the most
miserable, challenging,
and lonely years in my
nearly 60 years of membership
of the Labour party.
And I know that's what every Jew
sitting here tonight feels too.
The history of the last
four years is being rapidly
rewritten by those who
are seeking our support,
and my commitment to you is I
will not cease fighting until
we are clear that we have
eradicated anti-Semitism from
the soul of our
great Labour party.
I know all of these
individuals extremely well,
and they're all thoroughly
nice, thoroughly decent people.
And they're doing
a very tough job,
and we have to treat
them with respect.
Because you know,
we're just bloody
lucky to have people in
this country prepared
to put their necks on the
chopping block for our welfare.
Becky, did you stand up at
any point, and call it out?
I did, but was that enough?
No.
It wasn't.
And why?
What I did was, I did
speak in shadow cabinet
about this a few times.
I believe that you speak
out, and speak up in private,
and you try and
get something done.
If you can't get something
done and it's still wrong,
then you leave.
And you speak out,
and you speak up,
and you make sure that
something is done.
Oh no, I just sat there
thinking, I've got to shut up.
I mustn't say anything.
This was the big fight for the
heart and soul of the Labour
party.
If a Corbyn follower
succeeds Corbyn,
then I think the position
for Jews in the Labour party,
long-term, is
completely untenable.
Hi Jess.
Hi.
Jeremy Corbyn's office?
You are a breath of fresh
air, and that's why I'm sure
you've got a great future
in the Labour party.
But for me that's why I
wanted you as the leader.
That you were authentic,
you told it as it is.
That you were brave,
and that you really,
really could connect
with ordinary people.
And for me, in all the battles
that I've done through my life,
maybe the battle
against the BNP,
I understood from that
the absolute importance
of being both honest,
but really listening,
acting, and connecting.
And that's why you're so
important to the Labour
movement.
And will be in the future.
Well, let's hope so.
The idea of standing up,
regardless of the struggle,
regardless of how
difficult something is.
That sort of courage,
and that sort of bravery,
it has felt sometimes
as if that has just no
longer been part of the battle.
It was that we had to you
know agree with the crowd,
regardless of what
the crowd felt.
Yeah.
Truly, the other thing
I really feel strongly
is, in the anti-Semitism fight.
Oh gosh, yeah.
You know, it was the women.
It was totally...
And then, I will
never forget you.
Just after Luciana Berger had
decided to leave the Labour
party, and you rushed
over to sit behind her.
Behind her, yeah.
So you showed some
solidarity with her.
It's always been the women.
And then you demonstrated
in that very clear way,
that even though she felt forced
out she was still your sister.
Of course she will.
Labour women standing
shoulder to shoulder,
is the reason that I, no matter
how hard things get within
the Labour party, the
reason I cannot walk away is
because my life was genuinely
changed by the fact that loads
of Labour women came
in here in 1997.
They never ever
forgot to remember me,
people like me in the community.
Sure start.
Exactly.
Your sure start, your tax
credit, your childcare.
I will never, ever be able to
pay back the debt of the fact
that my children have
more secure lives
than I would have had they been
born under a Tory government.
And so the idea that has been
presented to us for the past
four or five years, whether
it's over anti-Semitism,
whether it's over women
within the Labour movement,
whether it's ever sexual
harassment - they've been like,
you're disloyal for struggling.
And I'm like, no, I'm here
to help the Labour party.
I didn't do it for
me, I did it because I
believe it's the right
thing for our movement.
And actually, I joined
the Labour party...
Because it's a struggle?
To fight it.
Fight.
How do you think you
square the circle
between the traditional
working class
support that we used to have,
and we want to get back,
and the more middle class,
liberal support that comes out
of the city?
It's absolutely not my
experience of working class
communities in the
Midlands and the north,
that they all hate immigrants,
or that they all...
Hate feminists.
The Labour party being the
party of the self-interest
of the masses has been lost,
because we stopped being able
to say the word self-interest.
And my nan and granddad -
my great-grandfather was one
of the people who set up
the independent Labour party
in Birmingham, and it
wasn't because he was...
had big ideas about the way
that the world should be.
It was because he
lived in a slum
and he didn't want to
live in a slum anymore.
He had self-interest.
And my nan and
granddad's politics
was about moving out of the
slum and getting a decent wage.
It was self-interested.
It wasn't so that
everybody has enough.
It was for them
and their families,
to be able to do all right.
And then their children, the
baby boomers, my parents,
they had enough to care about
everybody having enough,
and then it became an
ideological movement, rather
than a self-interested one.
But there's absolutely no
reason why you cannot square
ideologically wanting
everybody to have enough,
with the idea that you and your
family feel like we haven't got
enough and need it.
Those two things.
My nan and my mum, they're
cut from the same cloth,
they were the same, exactly
the same sort of person.
They both would have voted
Labour until they died,
and it was rooted in something
completely separate for both
of them.
That is the coalition.
I think we think it's a
harder job than it is,
to make people in Bassettlaw
feel the same way as people
in Brighton.
They essentially
do feel the same.
I feel like this should
now be an opportunity
to look up to the country
a little bit more.
To look up from the script.
I don't feel that
there's any sense
that world leaders
are getting together
to deal with the pandemic.
I don't quite know how
he's going to rise to that.
I think that the
connecting with the country
is vitally important.
Now, I think that he will
inevitably get a bounce.
Also, I hate this, because it is
got so much sort of, horrible,
sexist connotations - he
looks the part, doesn't he?
I hate that.
The number of people
who said to me...
I hate it too.
The number of people
who've said to me,
you've got to vote
for Keir, because just
think of if Boris implodes,
you trust Keir opposite you.
Why wouldn't you trust a woman?
Well.
Well, quite.
Absolutely.
But he's got good
hair, doesn't he?
I mean, he has got good hair.
My dad is always
like, lovely hair.
He's ticked that box,
but that is a tiny box
of connecting with the public.
I mean, I think we
can all understand
that the candidates
have got to build
a majority within the party.
Right?
Oh, absolutely.
But once that election
is over they've
got to turn to the public,
and they've got to be bold.
And that means not
sticking to what's happened
in the last five years.
It means breaking from that.
And last 20 years.
You have to think of...
Except.
I agree with that, but
the thing that really,
really pisses me off...
Is slagging off the
last Labour government.
Why would you slag off
your record in office
when the government's degrading
it all brilliantly by itself?
In the face of a Boris
Johnson government
- remember, he's got
a majority of 80,
and is he doing
anything with it?
I mean, if I had a majority
of 80 Margaret, just think.
Just even just one thing.
You'd be like, well OK, we're
going to end child poverty.
We're going to sort
the social care crisis.
You would just be like
I'd be like giddy,
like a child in a sweet shop.
So Jess, it may have been
a bit too early this time,
or it may have been
the wrong time,
but I want you to stand
again for the Labour party
leadership.
You've got to promise me you're
going to have a go at it.
I mean, I promise you
that I will have a go.
But regardless, I promise you
that I will always try and make
sure that I have the biggest
role that I can have in making
the Labour party
the best it can be.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I did say to people before
the election hang on in there
because the battle after the
election will be the most
important battle in the
life of the Labour party.
I now think that the way in
which the next leader chooses
to use that position will
be the most important.